in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about how modern technology
like social media has enhanced the
communication power of the presidency
now being president has a lot of
advantages but politically one of those
advantages is that as president you're
automatically newsworthy so
cameras and shows are going to be
interested in talking to you and hearing
what you have to say now this has always
been the case for presidents if they
wanted to publish an editorial in a
newspaper back in the 1790s they could
have done that but one major advantage
that presidents have today is advances
in communication technology and by that
i mean not only the
wealth of media choices that are out
there
in terms of channels
and methods of distribution like youtube
but also social media
like facebook or twitter
so why would presidents be interested in
using social media in the first place
well check out this graph
from the pew research center that shows
how much the following of politicians
has grown in just four years from 2010
to 2014.
you can see that it doesn't matter how
old
someone is or whether they're republican
or democrat
across the board the percent of
registered voters who follow candidates
for office
has doubled in just this short time so
what does this mean for the president in
particular well one thing it does is
make it much easier for the president to
do something called going
public and going public
is when
the president
goes directly to the electorate speaks
directly to the people
to gain support for their policies so
they're bypassing members of congress
and speaking directly to the electorate
to try to drum up support for whatever
policy they'd like to enact and the
range of diverse
media outlets that serve different
demographics means that it's pretty easy
for the president to speak directly to
whichever demographic he or she is
interested in talking to so they can
craft a message
that appeals to one specific demographic
for example let's take a look at an
appearance that former president barack
obama made on the internet show between
two ferns have you heard of the
affordable care act oh yeah i heard
about that that's the thing that doesn't
work why would you get the guy that
created the zune
to make your website healthcare.gov
works great now and millions of
americans have already gotten
health insurance plans and what we want
is for people to know that you can get
affordable health care and most young
americans right now they're not covered
and the truth is is that they can get
coverage all for
what it costs you
to pay your cell phone though so you'll
notice that in that clip
obama was speaking directly to young
people going through a show that young
people were likely to watch and even
using language that was geared toward
young people like saying that health
care costs about as much as your cell
phone bill all in service of trying to
promote the policy of the affordable
care act barack obama was also the first
president to create an official
presidential twitter handle
at potus
for president of the united states
which then in the transfer of power from
the obama administration to the trump
administration now is the official
twitter handle of donald trump
and trump is particularly well known for
using twitter to reach a broad audience
check out
this tweet
from july 5th
2018 which talks about trump's position
on immigration laws so let's read these
congress must pass
smart fast and reasonable immigration
laws now law enforcement at the border
is doing a great job but the laws they
are forced to work with are insane when
people with or without children enter
our country they must be told to leave
without our country being forced to
endure a long and costly trial
tell the people out and they must leave
just as they would if they were standing
on your front lawn hiring thousands of
judges does not work and is not
acceptable only country in the world
that does this
so you can see what trump is doing here
is speaking directly to the people and
asking them to influence congress in
support of his policy stance so using
twitter allows trump to speak to
more than 50 million followers and it
allows the president to have a rapid
response
to events as they unfold
so instead of
having to wait for a newspaper to print
an editorial tomorrow or on sunday it's
possible to speak to
the electorate within minutes of an
important event happening so overall
modern technology and social media have
really
increased the impact of the president's
power to communicate with the electorate
to get out policy initiatives and to
advertise them and to speak quickly and
directly to the people